i've been meaning to talk about this
for two days now we just we've run out
of time each day but i have to get to
whoopi goldberg whoopi goldberg made a
very impolitic comment about the
holocaust
she has now been suspended there are
calls for her to be fired she's furious
that she was suspended at all
here's the comment in case you haven't
heard it
well also if you're going to do this
then let's be truthful about it because
the holocaust isn't about race
no
no
it's not about racism
it's about a different race but it's
it's not about race
it's not about race
because
it's about man's inhumanity to man
that's what it's about but it's about
white supremacy
but it's not it's not about ideology
but these are two white groups of people
how do we have to blame
him as white
people you're missing the point the
minute you turn it into race it goes
down this alley let's talk about it for
what it is it's how people treat each
other
it's a problem it doesn't matter if
you're black or white because black
white jews uh it's how everybody eats
each other so is it
if you're uncomfortable if you hear
about mouse
should you be worried to should your
child say oh my god i i wonder if that's
me no that's not what they're going to
say they're going to say i don't want to
be like that
i
i want you to pull over if you're
driving i want if you are watching this
or listening to this and i want you to
sit down because i have
i think the most contrarian take on this
whole episode of anyone that i have
heard on either side of the aisle
while whoopi goldberg is obviously 100
wrong as an historical matter
i think she kind of makes a good point
all right i just i said it i said it i
know people are going to be shocked and
offended and ran their garments and
clutch their pearls
she is 100
wrong as a matter of history hitler very
much perpetrated the holocaust because
he hated the jews he viewed the jews as
a race not just as a religious group but
as a race the jews historically are a
race and a religion it's very difficult
for modern people to understand that a
tribe of people
and a religion of people could be the
same thing because in modernity we don't
really think of tribes anymore we don't
really think of nations anymore we think
that any people can be part of any
religion and the two are completely
separated that was not true in the
ancient world that is not true
historically of judaism actually that
idea is really a product of christianity
when christianity comes and saint paul
says that there is neither jew nor greek
nor slave nor free but all are one in
christ jesus that is a pretty radical
and novel idea and so because
christianity shapes the development of
the west is the most important feature
that shaped the development of the west
then that's how we think of things but
that wasn't always true and that is not
the case with judaism so yes whoopi is
wrong
that the holocaust was not about race
and the holocaust specifically refers to
hitler's
genocide of the jews hitler also killed
millions of ukrainians hitler also
killed millions of russians hitler also
killed lots and lots of catholics hitler
also killed what half a million gypsies
something like that hitler hitler also
killed lots and lots of other people
that's not really what we're referring
to with the holocaust they are separate
things hitler killed a lot of people
and he he killed the jews because
they're a race however the point that
whoopi makes that i really like that i
think actually is a pretty conservative
point
is that
when we're talking about something even
this you know is extremely evil i guess
the most extremely evil thing you can
think of in modernity the holocaust
the essence of that evil is not race we
are really tempted these days especially
by the left to say that every bad thing
is racism that racism is the most evil
thing in the world there is nothing more
evil than racism it is the core evil
this is why the original sin of america
is racism that's the language they use
but it's not the original sin of america
all of the original sin of the whole
world is original sin and it's deeper
the issue here is that the imagination
of man's heart is evil from the very
beginning you can't boil down the evil
in the world just to race
it's it's deeper than that it's actually
more fundamental than that
and and so would be i don't i bet you
whoopi goldberg would have no idea what
i'm talking about if i explained to her
the implications of the things that you
were saying and if i corrected her on
the historical record but that point is
very important because if we try to boil
down all evil to race
we're going to come up short
it's much much deeper than that and it's
and ultimately it is religious and that
and and because all human conflict is
theological you've got to get down to
that issue too and the more that we just
babble and prattle about race the worse
off we're going to be constant contact
is a digital marketing platform that
helps small businesses and non-profits
of all sizes build grow and succeed i
have used constant contact
for over a dozen years now it is just
the og
reliable extremely sophisticated always
is going to work email marketing contact
management system it's just great i've
trusted it for over a decade they've got
industry leading list growth tools
social media ads and more constant
contact helps small businesses connect
with customers find new ones and sell
online all from one easy to use platform
they've been trusted by millions of
businesses to help improve their
marketing
with a 97 deliverability rate you can
rest assured that your customers and
potential customers are getting the
right message at the right time with
very simple interface even i could use
it constant contact's easy to use
platform makes contact management easier
than ever they've got powerful
automation tools it's just it's so
simple to use to start your free digital
marketing trial today visit
constantcontact.com
ah
gotta ring the bell then you get
notifications if you're not getting
notifications head on over to apple
podcast spotify stitcher google play
wherever you get your audio podcast
subscribe to the michael knowles show
leave a five star review
we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]